[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm your host mike sacks in for brian
buckmeyer now the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial is expected
to resume next monday ahead of that
we're giving you a complete recap of the
trial so far
after pleading guilty to dozens of
murder and attempted murder charges the
parkland school shooter now faces a
penalty phase where a broward county
jury will decide his fate jurors will
either hand down a sentence of life in
prison or the death penalty on february
14 2018 the shooter opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school 17
people were killed and 17 more injured
after weeks of jury selection
prosecutors presented their opening
statement on july 18th
i'm going to speak to you
about the unspeakable
about this defendant goal directed
planned
systematic murder
mass murder
of 14 children
an athletic director
a teacher and a coach
these brutal murders occurred
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
in parkland florida
and it happened on february the 14th
2018
three days before
these brutal murder this massacre
the defendant in this case
made a cell phone video on his cell
phone and this is what the defendant
said
hello
my name is nick
i'm going to be
the next school shooter of 2018.
my goal is at least 20 people
with an ar-15 and some tracer rounds
the defense indicated it would wait and
present its opening statement after the
prosecution finishes its case joining us
today is co-host terry austin and trial
attorney krista ramy krista you first
what do you make of the prosecution's
opening statement you just heard there
it was a very good opening statement one
of the things you want to do when you
open is make that connection with the
jury he spoke to them without a single
note he remembered everybody's name he
didn't miss a beat on anything it was
compelling and sad and all of the things
that you want it to be but the way he
walked around the room and used the
space
it just shows how much you know he knows
this case and how much he's invested in
it
and terry was it strategic for the
defense to hold off on presenting its
opening statement was that a good idea
you know what mike it was strategic and
it's not unheard of there are defense
attorneys who do that what they want to
do is to hear the prosecution's case and
they only want to address the necessary
issues any issues that the prosecution
might have raised but i think i would
have done an opening because the jury
wants to hear a story no matter what
that story is and of course the defense
attorney can always just say wait until
you hear all of the evidence some of the
evidence he could have talked about was
the evidence regarding the defendant's
mental health
regarding his background his family he
had a very difficult upbringing he did
not know his birth parents he could have
mentioned that during the opening or she
could have mentioned it the
prosecution's team could have mentioned
it and none of that was mentioned and it
might have helped because when the jury
is listening to all of the negative
horrible information in the back of
their minds they might be a little bit
more sensitive if they can hear that
there's mental illness involved terry
krista thank you for that analysis and
stay with us because still ahead on law
and crime daily we will continue our
coverage of the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial please stay with us
[Music]
welcome back testimony in the parkland
school penalty phase trial began on july
18th as survivors and family members of
victims were called to the stand
alexander duret was both as he was shot
by the gunman and survived but his
brother was shot and killed
while i was sitting there you know just
trying not to
think this is real thinking it's you
know fake
um you know and then
just not trying to process you know
what's going on and then
um
while i'm sitting there you know i have
a couple people around me
that are just you know
trying also not to you know freak out
and uh
then
i remember feeling trickling down the
back of my head and onto my chest
and then you know i touched the back of
my head and then my hand was all bloody
i saw
alex shachner
passed away
over his desk
kind of like half of his body
there was like a metal bar on the desk
and half of his body was off the bar and
the other half was like still kind of in
a seat
and uh i saw a pile of blood like
forming under him
and i saw his body
not spasming but more like trying to
take his like final breaths
um
and then at that moment you know it
started getting more real
jurors also heard from survivor danielle
gilbert who described what happened when
gunshots rang out
tell us what happens after you go near
miss riovan's desk so
then we go over to the other side of the
classroom by her desk
and at this time he still hadn't shot
into our classroom at that point we were
just sitting kind of like sitting ducks
um we had no way to protect ourselves no
way to stand up for ourselves
and um
once we were all kind of in over by the
um
door and away from the door that's when
he had shot into our classroom
he injured four people in my classroom
one of them
being fatal
and from there we just kind of sat and
waited until the police came and took us
out of the classroom and did you do
anything to record what was it what was
occurring
yes um
i'm not exactly sure why but my initial
instinct was to pick up my phone and
start recording um and so i did i took
several videos of what was happening
one of those videos was shown in court
members of the gallery and the witness
broke down in tears as it played we will
only play the audio but we do want to
warn you the following clip could be
disturbing to some viewers
[Music]
c
oh
[Music]
window
terry the witness seemed a bit hesitant
to discuss why she took the video but do
you think that video will be critical
evidence
well you know i'm so glad she did take
the video she might have been hesitant
because she felt a little guilty taking
a video when people were getting shot
but there was probably nothing else she
could do that evidence is going to be
crucial in this case because it shows
the perspective of those students what
they saw what they heard and it allows
the jury to hear that as well and i
think that that's important body cam
video is one thing but getting that
perspective from inside the room when
they were being shot at by the defendant
i think is something that the jury needs
to see particularly since this is a
penalty stage this is whether or not
it's life or death and so i do think
that they need to hear what those
students were going through and you
could see that the witness on the stand
herself she was going through it again
so it might have been difficult to
record but it's good that we have it and
krista that audio that we heard was so
powerful and several parents removed
themselves from the courtroom is
something like that jurors take notice
of
well yeah i mean the jurors are stuck
there they're they're listening to it
too um and i think that they're
recognizing i know that when i'm
watching this i'm recognizing as a
parent myself
that these people are bearing witness to
possibly their own child's death
by listening to this video and i you
know i cannot even imagine
what that must feel like and nor do i
ever want to but the jury is watching
this feeling the same types of emotions
that we are but more closely held
because they're seeing the video not
just hearing it
and then they're watching these parents
reactions i
i think that it's overwhelming and it
and it goes to the
the
you know aggravating factors that it was
done in a cold calculated um you know
prete uh without any pretense or of
moral or justification it shows the jury
exactly what they see yeah and coming up
on lawn crime daily we take a closer
look at the moments after the marjory
stoneman douglas high school shooting
where the gunman visited just minutes
after the massacre and who he spoke with
before his arrest
[Music]
welcome back as the parkland school
shooter penalty phase continues witness
testimony causes emotional reactions
from parents of students who were killed
i observed a
child dead on the ground
on the left and there was like a smoke
and dust in the air
and i observed other officers a little
bit further ahead
i checked one room on the left-hand side
and then i went up to uh the front of
the officers that were there they were
clearing
the kids out of the rooms
and myself and another
officer went towards the front to kind
of
keep them covered as they were pulling
kids out i am over jamie gutenberg okay
and uh what happened you checked your
any vital signs yes i checked your vital
signs for breath and for pulse i found
none um and
uh i checked several times
and then
we held there for a moment and uh
officer schmidt and i heard a voice we
thought coming from the hallway okay and
what did you guys do
we cracked the door uh confirmed that
somebody in the hallway was asking for
help and we decided we were going to
move into the hallway to go get them we
moved into the hallway and walked
towards the voice which turned out to be
anthony borges
made contact with him
i was still looking down the hallway
covering in case we encountered a
subject
and the officers
dragged him back to get him into the
hallway to provide medical care
jurors were also shown surveillance
video of cruz just minutes after the
massacre when he visited mcdonald's and
later bought an icee from a subway
restaurant
i mean i saw him sit down so i just was
telling him you know like this is so
chaotic you know this is crazy all these
helicopters and swat cars coming like
what do you think this could be and
i don't remember him saying much but he
was just
head down wasn't really talking to me i
don't remember much of the conversation
but
i was doing most of the talking he asked
me for a ride
um
he was pretty insistent on it and i said
no
i just
i wasn't really thinking
much of it i mean i was just trying to
get home my sister wasn't answering her
phone i was
nervous i was panicked i didn't i also
had a bad
gut feeling about it do you see you yes
which one is you
the one on the green shirt in that
do you remember what you were serving
him
uh he wanted an icy mixed
it was a cherry and a blue raspberry
based on those videos the shooter seemed
nonchalant in the minutes after the
massacre what do you think is going
through the jury's mind seeing that
i think it shows that he was cold and
calculated and
had no moral compass whatsoever it i i
don't know that a mental defect explains
this
um i think that it's some of the most
damaging evidence um because he is just
going about his day like nothing
happened
and um
and what's ironic to me is that then you
know a few you know minutes later he
surrenders to the police peacefully
without any fight
um i think that the jurors see this and
think that this is a man without a soul
i do
and terry the prosecution is trying to
prove several aggravating factors do you
think this video will help them prove
any of those factors
oh absolutely no question about it one
of those seven aggravating factors is
cold calculated and premeditated as
christa mentioned and his actions before
during and after the shooting shows that
he was definitely all of those things he
had no hesitancy to go up to that school
he ordered an uber as if he was going
out to a nightclub he actually told the
uber driver to go a certain way so he
could get positioned and go into the
school and then he goes into the school
the way he goes up to each floor and
shoots the students goes room by room
there's no question that he is told and
calculated no mercy breaking the windows
of those rooms knowing that those
students are sitting there
and are afraid for their lives and he's
just shooting them all and the fact that
after he leaves he throws the gun down
he knows he's guilty it doesn't show
mental illness it shows that he knows
he's guilty he throws the gun down he
goes to a mcdonald's and he goes and he
orders food and drink and he's talking
to someone like nothing ever happened no
question about it this man definitely
has mental issues but is cold calculated
and premeditated and when we come back
week two comes to a close in the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial hear testimony from the man who
sold the gunman his weapon and the uber
driver who dropped him off at the high
school
[Music]
back as the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial stretched into its
second week jurors heard even more
testimony from shooting survivors
i was in fourth period um just sitting
there writing an essay and then
heard loud sounds like the gunshots and
then
everyone began to run in the classroom
um i had ran towards the back towards
the teacher's desk
and
i was on the ground uh
i had my hand and i was crawling against
around the ground
okay and then what happened and then um
we sat there for about
20 minutes or less than 20 minutes
probably and then um
the police had came into our classroom
and escorted us out
did you get shot yes all right when did
you get shot and where did you get shot
um when i was sitting or sitting or
running towards the back of the room in
my right arm in my lower right back okay
so what what happened as a result of
your injuries
um i have a couple fragments still in my
lower back and then um i have a scar on
my arm as well
jurors later heard from laura zucchini
the uber driver who dropped the shooter
off at marjory stoneman douglas high
school
i picked him up and he comes in the car
and he told me and he told me
he was going to his music class
and that's all okay he said he was going
to music class did he have anything with
him
yes he had a big well right now i know
it's a backpack but for me in that time
it was a case
a guitar case he asked me if i was you
know
he i was
from the neighborhood so from the area
right i know i told him no that that i
pick up some passengers and
they're up in the area that's all okay
and
uh did you observe what he was doing if
anything while he was in the back seat
of your uh rav4 well he was on on the on
the phone
jurors were also shown the ar-15 the
shooter used in the massacre as
prosecutors called the man who sold him
the weapon to the stand
you have any procedures you follow every
customer is engaged in in conversation
um
we look for any
red flags any signs of why the sales
should not happen
if for any reason
anyone was uncomfortable
with anything about the sale the sale
did not happen period okay
and did you
engage that conversation with nicholas
cruz i had a brief conversation i
believe on pickup as i stated in my
deposition
i came out and asked him
what are you going to do with the rifle
and the reply was
i go shooting with my friends on the
weekends i just want my own stuff
now krista what sort of impact does
displaying the murder weapon have on
jurors how do you think they reacted to
that testimony just there
so the the merchant didn't do anything
wrong right i mean he sold a weapon um
that he was allowed to sell so that
wasn't the purpose of this testimony the
purpose was to show the the
premeditation that was involved and it
had an impact and you know as we know he
lied about why he purchased it and we
know why he purchased it um and it also
um
as it goes to the planning that that
that took place he bought this gun
relatively short in time you know less
than a year before the shooting and then
he starts all of these posts where he
starts uh you know researching how he
was going to commit his crime so it all
kind of is pieces in the puzzle that the
prosecution is laying out
right we know that he had google
searches for the type of weapon ar-15s
he was searching for soft guitar case
very things that you saw there on the
video the weapon you heard the uber
driver talk about how he carried the
weapon into the school now terry the
prosecution is expected to rest its case
sometime next week but the trial is
expected to last for months what can we
expect going forward
well you know it's a very good question
because you would think that the
prosecution would have many more
witnesses but i do think that the
defense is going to put on a lot of
witnesses and the prosecution will be
cross-examining those witnesses and
it'll be two types of witnesses one to
talk about the mental health of the
defendant and two to talk about his
difficult childhood so i'm expecting
that we will see multiple medical
experts talking about his mental health
or the lack thereof they're going to be
pointing to like you said mike those
searches on the computer to indicate the
fact that he is having some mental
difficulty and as far as his childhood
is concerned he did not know his birth
parents he was adopted at birth and his
brother was also adopted at a very young
age and then ultimately his adopted
parents passed away when he was
relatively young and i'm certain that
the defense is going to bring some of
that in and there's also a video of the
brother who is saying to the defendant i
love you no matter what i'm here for you
so that will be shown as a matter of
life and death for nicholas cruz life
behind bars or going to the death
chamber thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you